[Musique]
à petite île fini les allées venus entre
les services du département bienvenue à
la nouvelle Maison Départementale où
tous seront désormais regroupés ce
nouvel équipement de proximité situé au
100 chemin la guerre a été inauguré ce
jeudi 20 octobre en présence du
président Cyril Melchior et du maire
Serge Waro offrir à la population un
service public de qualité et proposer
une prise en charge globale des usagers
et des familles dans un seul et même
lieu voilà la volonté de la collectivité
et bien nous avons aujourd'hui inauguré
la Maison Départementale de petite île
c'est quoi la Maison Départementale de
petite ville c'est un lieu d'accueil
pour les usagers poils et familles les
administrer qui ont besoin de rencontrer
les services du département et bien il
faut aller dans les maisons
départementales et ici à petite île le
service du département était éclatés sur
trois sites différents dans les a
regroupés un bâtiment tout neuf dans ce
beau quartier de petit île et pour nos
propres services et bien il y aura ici
dans cette maison départementale une PMI
donc la petite enfance vous aurez aussi
le service polyvalence et sur quoi les
familles qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement social accompagnement
alimentaire amélioration de l'habitat
ainsi à son pour les jeunes à travers le
R+ et vous avez aussi les services de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance de l'ASE moi
je voudrais dire merci à tous les agents
du Département qui réalisent un travail
formidable et ici un petit île et bien
il y aura de très bonnes conditions de
travail soit les agents de petite équipe
ce ne sont pas moins de 19 agents qui
assureront la prise en charge des
usagers au sein de cette maison
départementale de petite île
très heureux en tant que mère de petite
île d'avoir cet équipement qui s'ouvre à
notre population le département a tenu
son engagement dans sa politique de
proximité vis-à-vis des administrés et
nous avons cette chance aujourd'hui
d'avoir regroupé tous les services du
département qui interviennent sur le
territoire et sur le canton 22 donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un bel
équipement un bel outil il faut que
maintenant que la population Vienne
fréquenter cet outil et je compte sur
les petites lillois et les petites
lillois pour venir régulièrement ici au
besoin bien évidemment mais pour savoir
que le département est à la proximité
des petites lilloises et des petits
Tillois des conditions d'accueil du
public et de travail des équipes
améliorées pour une réponse plus
performante des services sociaux aux
besoins de la population
[Musique]